Speaker 1: Last week, we talked to you about O.N
being dropped by some cable networks, the extreme
right wing propaganda network own. It is not
just OANN that some cable providers are dropping
Newsmax. The also right wing crazy network to the
right of Fox News is being quietly dropped by a
number of different cable providers,
and this is getting less attention,
but it's just as interesting. Next TV reporting
Newsmax quietly dropped by Atlantic Broadband,
Cincinnati Bell and other cable operators
conservative channels carriage issues emerge
as rival 000+ faces pay TV oblivion,
and the article actually says
while the focus has been on One America
news and its recent carriage struggles,
Newsmax has also quietly lost distribution. Since
December 31st. Newsmax has been pulled off the
pay-TV grids of cable operators, including
Atlantic Broadband, Cincinnati Bell, South
Carolina's Hard Gray Communications and Central
Pennsylvania's Blue Ridge Communications. These
are just the cable systems we know about that
have dropped Newsmax now, as is often the case,
the article says. It's unclear whether the
carriage disruptions are part of an expiration
of a master carriage deal signed in 2015, or
if these issues are related to the politics
of these channels, as Oman has with its upcoming
ouster from DirecTV. New York based Newsmax has
attributed its recent blackout troubles to
quote censorship of conservative voices.
Newsmax said despite our high ratings with
personalities like Greg Kelly, Eric Bolling,
Sean Spicer, Lindsay Keith, Dick Morris,
Alan Dershowitz and more. That's funny.
It's clear Blue Ridge doesn't like Newsmax point
of view. The cable operators framed the issue
in standard carriage award terms. It is just
business. You know, it's this is actually funny.
I've mentioned this before. I actually am in touch
with someone at sort of in a position of, I guess,
to the extent that you can have power at Newsmax,
sort of a powerful position at Newsmax. And this
person is very reasonable politically. And I know
that it's it's for for sure to say it's just a job
kind of diminishes the corrosive and destructive
nature of these channels. But not everybody who I
mean, it's a product. At the end of the day, it's
a destructive product. It's sort of like saying,
well, opioids are just a product. It's amoral.
Well, no opioids have destroyed the lives of a lot
of people, and they've been incredibly effective
for people in serious pain as well. And that
doesn't you, OK? So it's either way it has an
effect. But Newsmax, to me, is more interesting
than OANN. Not because it's less crazy,
although the content is marginally less crazy.
But because from what I know, the only people
really seem to be true believers in the insanity
in a way that at least some of the people at
Newsmax are not. Now, it doesn't seem to be
particularly helping them with cable networks.
And as a reminder, it is not censorship not to
be on a cable network. I would love for my show
to be on every cable network. It's not. I'm not
being censored. There's just a lot of shows and
not every cable network is going to take my show.
If Harvard doesn't want me to speak there, I'm
not being censored. I just don't have a right to
speak at Harvard, and people may or may not want
to hear from me at Harvard. And even if some do,
and some don't. I don't have any right to show up
and speak there, and I think this is where a lot
of these right wingers sort of
deliberately or out of ignorance
don't they don't really understand what censorship
actually means. But Newsmax struggling with cable
networks as his own, and we'll see what
their cable carriage looks like as we get
closer and closer to the November midterms.
It actually could make a difference because
there are some of the loudest voices. Amplifying
Republican candidates in these upcoming elections,
which now I mean, we're there nine months away.
We're nine months from the midterm elections.